you
hope in Eastern Europe what the EU can
learn from Lithuania in the interview
Lithuanian president Dalia Gribble
skater congratulations mrs. president
you have been awarded the cards price to
honor what you have done for European
unity are you proud of it
I am proud for my people because I threw
this award to defend not to me
personally this is Cuba's Katya the
European Union is in its deepest crisis
ever there are voices that one if the
euro crisis gets worse that it might
break up the entire EU to your share
this view never the first it is not our
crisis it is the financial and economic
crisis in some member states for example
Baltic states we already recovered and
we're growing in the face of more than
3% GDP so that means mainly how I
evaluate of course it is global things
which started to influence Europeans
finances and economy but many disguises
are unresponsible political decisions
which have been a few decades going on
and yeah they made reasons of it will be
talking about the EU in crisis later in
depth let's first take a brief look at
your career in politics you have been
Lithuanian president since the summer of
2009 before you served as a minister in
many different cabinets but you're not a
member of a political party why not
personally I have allergy to political
membership in any political party
because I was supposed to be in one
party 23 years ago so now I try to avoid
it I think that if you work as
professional and do well your job you
can do it no matter in what political
affiliation you are but what kind of
politician did the Lithuanians get when
they made you their head of state many
labor you a conservative is that right
is that the way you see yourself
no I don't think I'm conservative or
socialist as
said ideologically I try not to be
fellate it with anybody I do what is
necessary to do for country and I never
treat myself as poor politician always
try to be professional and what I do try
to do the best I can
can you name a statesman who was or
perhaps still is a kind of role model
for you a lot I was interested very much
in leadership myself was reading
historic and biographical books strat
starting from Gandhi Churchill Thatcher
Merkel now a lot of people can inspire
if you look to the history seriously
you grew up in the Soviet Union you
mentioned it already and you became an
economist then you were a teacher at a
college which was which was run by the
Communist Party what did you do when you
understood that things you teach your
students might be wrong I was teaching
only economics and history economy mind
so there was nothing bad about it we
started for example my lessons we're
going from Aristotle's theories after
Marxism so that was curiosity for me and
was very interesting what I was doing
myself so also I was teaching the
history of money of the world money's
starting from small coins has for
example shuttle one price copy up to the
internet and artificial - what we have
now as hedge funds or instruments so I
was purely economist and I think already
at that time I was teaching only
objective messages and theories
Lithuania is one of the three Baltic
states that emerged from the Soviet
Union those three countries joined NATO
and the European Union ten years ago in
2004 99 years ago Moscow and how today
still seems to be reluctant to accept
entirely is Russia still a threat to
your country I think that still 9 years
are not so large time for nations for
their mentality for their history for
the sensitivities we have between
neighbors for the historic paints we had
between our neighbors and why still some
sensitivities exist especially we feel
it via militarization around the borders
we feel it with economic pressures
especially by energy prices so still
sensitivity same place but I was told
once that neither time I their 20s not
enough maybe we need 40 years for
generations to change for the this
sensitive memories to be gone to be able
to cooperate to with our neighbors so
I'm equal footing with the respect each
other let's go to the you and move to
Brussels the EU itself is not seems not
to be too popular these days with
Europeans some preliminary results to
the former Soviet Union describing the
you as an over centralized soft super
state I think I can say that these
people who say that another being in
Soviet Union so we know what that means
and of course Brussels or European Union
is union of member states which was
organized by goodwill and peacefully
without forcing anybody to go to this
union so why all decisions in union
we're doing ourselves that means in the
council has of member states of each
country we together deciding we taking
responsibility in this our decisions
what Europe will be in future so nobody
enforced us neither one countries
dominating it is our decision common
decision about everything what we're
deciding so to compare European Union
with a server type I think it's more
propaganda element which is coming from
some
areas outside european union but at the
same time fear of too much integration
is widespread look at britain they are
going to have an in/out referendum how
much damage would it cost if the UK left
the EU i don't want to speculate on bad
things and it's up to any country to
design on its own future but even for
britain even for anybody union was
created to help each other to have peace
prosperity and security in the world
of course if crisis is taking too long
people sometimes losing patience during
any crisis there anti-european
or anti governmental modes are
increasing but sometimes our national
politicians using and looking for excuse
on we're outside and it is easier to say
some Brussels but what means Brussels
there is no Brussels as it is it is
Member States head of member states who
are sitting and deciding in Brussels
just only place the name or place but
European Union is a unit of member
states in this time of crisis the drama
transfer miss marker is often severely
criticized for her firm stance on
austerity and budget consolidation has
German become too dominant within the EU
I think it is a little bit perception
about Germany now than also partly on
purpose because Germany never been only
for very strict measures it's about both
the economy economizing the expenditures
but also the stimulus and structural
reform need to go in tact and this is
how Germany is saying and behaving but
of course it is easier failing in on
national arena to look for somebody to
blame and hear exactly what I am seeing
that some national and responsible
behavior for decades in some other
states now tries to be put on the
shoulders of responsibilities of one or
another country but Germany in this
situation is taking very responsible
steps and Chancellor is responsible to
the German people also she cannot allow
to use them
German people's money to bail out some
Member States who do not do any homework
and do not do their structure reforms
and are not taking responsibility by
themselves how difficult was it for you
to convince your Lithuanians of the
necessity of Gutzon of austerity was not
easy but the main thing is to explain to
be trusted if you say that means you are
saying what reality and what
reinstallation is second you need to
take burden off cuts fastly on your own
I mean for people in political elite and
who is earning the most trying to
protect the least receiving least
protected social groups of people and to
be a personal example to cut your salary
to return part of your salary to
Treasury to fly on cheap flights
whatever it takes to be an example if we
look at the you as a whole
you have the northern countries led by
Germany and you have on the other hand a
sort of Latin belt led by France do you
agree that the euro crisis is revealing
a split of completely opposing political
cultures I don't want to exaggerate it
and I again not never using that it is
our crisis it is it is global financial
crisis yes partly it is depth state
depth crisis yes but it's not our crisis
so why it is about business mentality
about business practices about political
responsibility which is dominates in one
another countries yes sometimes we can
see common elements more common in
Nordic countries in in Germany then
let's say some behavior or history of
political behavior in some other
countries but I don't want to generalize
I think that each country is different
that's how Europe is about but we always
were able to find joint agreements at
least frameworks how we are working
together we cannot dictate to any
country to do exactly that way
that one-size-fits-all that's not
possible any methods any any features
how to fight crisis needs to be
familiarized and customized to their
country's history country's mentality
how politics is is gone so you cannot do
everything in the same way but general
requirements general responsibilities
general targets needs to be more or less
the same mrs. president your favorite
sports is karate your whole bus watch a
basketball also I'm listening how
without basketball but you hold a black
belt in martial arts
does it help when you do politics I
think that yes because it's not about
just pure martial as it is about
philosophy of life it's about Memphis
how you work and discipline including
discipline or and self discipline in
your life
Dalia Global's character president of
Lithuania thank you very much for
joining us on door travaileth thank you